tan
えええええぞーーー
yeah
いいいいいい
[音楽]
母こんにちは
[拍手]
ひぁっ中です今日
結構大それたテーマです
世界は数学でできているどうでしょう皆さん世界は数学でできてるって思ったことある
方いらっしゃいます
いますでいい感じですねちょっとあの早速ですね皆さんにもあっほんとだっていう
ところですね
ちょっと見てみ
いただきたいと思いますが本日
2019年の10月5日
これを8ケタで表すと20191005
このハチ北ですね
円周率のどこにあるかということを検索した結果がこちらです
逆彩木じゃないですね一丁一丁より1億1213141577 keter
焼ステーキ会のところですねそこにこの22
0191005がーこのちゃんとした並びで存在しています
を聞いたのはですね最安ナビゲーターの桜井進さんという方から
まあこういうようなことができるんじゃないかということで実際に彼はイベントとかで
行っていますけれども
じゃあもっともっと楽しくこういったものをですね
検索できるものができないかという事で今日作ってきます
したはいこちらですねちょっとあの皆さんに画面で見せられれば良かったんですが
ちょっとそれができなくて
手持ちにしました私は
線
972年
12月
30日ですこれで検索をすると徐行予算と一番繋がるとざらざらきます
すると出ました16603021991家ために今の並び19721230が8ケタで
出てきます
今多分現存し
で生まれている方の中でですね一番早い早い方っていうのがですね実は最近産まれた子
なんですよ
それすごいですよえっとね羽扇19年
9月16かこれ計測しますよ
しました
244桁目に出る方
これがですね今生まれた人の中で一番早く火つける端桁です
まぁこんな風な形でですね
ちょっと皆さん世界は数学で出来てるなーって思ってくださいましたかねぇ
そうですね今頷いているのでたブースを守ってくれたと思います
そうなんですねまあこういうような形で今
技術はどんどん進歩しています今年も14mar に google が発表したのは
この演習実は何桁になったか
それは31兆4000をかけた
これオシャレですね14mar に発表したんですよ
日ですねいいですねそうです31兆4世を区
ちょっとシャレじゃないですか数学も実はおしゃれにできるんですよね
こんなちょっとでやっぱりオシャレじゃないと思ってますよね
でもオシャレなんですよこういうようなところですねやっぱり
数学て今までて
こんな感じじゃないですか3竜7は18たちには10なんかもう決められたものを解き
なさい
はぁもう遠くしかないそんな感じでやっていたと思います
でもこれからは違うんですよね
10わっわ
って聞かれたときにみなさん何考えます10貼っって聞かれて
答えは分限にあります
中はと聞かれたら今みたいな e +8
永田さんあそれだけかもしれないでもか計算にすれば
引き算にセラ実は無限に存在します
1610-10おくこれだけでも中になりますよね
その時に自分が何を訴えたいかどうしてこの式を選んだのか
そういった所まで含めて説明をするそういうようなことによって自分の考え方をもっと
皆さんに充てるすること
ができるというようなことがですねやっぱりオープンマインドのアプローチという形に
なってきます
まあ私はこういう職業柄ですねなんとかこの算数数学というものを僕皆さんに面白く
伝えられないかなぁと
先ほど音ですねあの桜井先生にを取りますし
例えばこの地下
腕横浜国大のですね今副学長の音が店は先生性というですね
数学者がいますが彼なんかもですね
世界を数学で出来てるよって言うことを言ってくれるんですけども僕らはもっともっと
身近の人たちにどんな形で伝えられるかということを考えていきたいと思っています
例えばこれやったことなんですけれども東大寺の大仏殿の中にですね
数学の問題を掲示させていただきました
三楽と言いますで実際に使った問題なんですけれどもこれはどういった問題かというと
大仏が立ち上がって
東海道五十三次を歩いた時いったい何日かかるでしょうかという問題をあの作りました
でこれどうですかねどんな風に考えます
ここにあるのは
ちょっとした
ところだと座高がだいたい15メートルですね
まあそういったところを考えると当時坐像は
立像のちょうど半分で作るというのがルールでした
なので立ち上がると30m なんですよね30m
じゃあその30メートルで計算してまーどういう風になるかというとまあ結構
応募してくれたですね
作品というか回答の中では1日弱ぐらいで着くというようなことで別に罫線で出た人も
いるんですけどもいろんな答えがあったんですよ
どんな答え箇所上がりますすごいですよ
そもそもならから
日本ば側でどういったのきっとこれじゃねーかと実利日
一瞬でついたんじゃないかとなのでこんなので1周でしょう
いう人もいたり
あと大仏さんて慈悲深いですよねきっと
伊達お釈迦様ですね
そうするとそれぞれの宿場町でいろいろ説法してくれてですね
なので
五十三次なので504日目でついたとかいう答えを出してくれた人もいました
でも私はそれこそ考えた結果ということはこの考えるということも数学なんじゃないか
なと実は思っています
うわぁそれっていうのは mathematica の
ちょっと s がズルじゃないですねばせバック2の原型というのはマテーマって言う
これ原型の言葉でこの由来はですね学ぶべきこと人として学ぶべきことっていうのは
考えていくことです
何かを考えるということができればそれこそ数学なんだよと
だから今まで
すごくが受験とかでやってきた数学というのはもちろんそれも数学だし
今日何食べようかしらこれ何か売りかな
これでいいのかしらこれを悩んで選択するのの
これも数学って言っていいんじゃないかなと
そんな風に思っているわけです
まあ今ですねステム教育とかスティーム教育というようなことがですね
今の教育業界ではどんどんでできる言葉ですけども
ステム教育は聞いたことある人ってこう今すぐですティムも大丈夫ですね c 棟大と
いうのはアートが入って
ステムの s は saas でティーダ局のレジでいいがエンジニアリングの web
がまあスマート曲です
そしてそこの中にだんだとへという領域が入ってきて
パーツが
その中に入れてそれを総合的にですね
学習していこうというようなことがですね
特にアメリカとか中国とかそういったところでどんどんと進められています
まあここの中でお気づきの方もいると思いますがこの m
この m がですね一番最後に来るのこれ何でかなと
いろんなことがありますけども私は社会の土台としてこの場所までですがあるという
ような事をですね位置づけている
そんなところにもあるんじゃないかなと
そんな解釈をしています
これ
ちょっとあのをがらりとですね話の流れが変わってきますけれどもこれ
l 9分と言いますこの言葉は私が考えました
なんで考えたかってそれちゃんと商標登録を生かしたからですね
一応私が考えたということになっているんですけど何度約かと
life love ラーニングのですね訳です
日本がこれまで生涯学習という文化をですね
随分と大事にしてきました例えば
茶道とかかどうとか道の精神があることによってですね
あのー今まで自分が学ぼうと思っていたことを生涯にわたって学んでいくという姿勢
ですそういったところに例えば検定文化も
関係とか英検とかまぁは言えの2件とかですね
そういった検定文化もやはりこういうような位置づけになっているんじゃないか
4歳人たちはどんどんどんどん高いレベルを目指してもいいし
先に行っちゃってる人でもですねもう一軒学び直しをしてもいいし
そんな自由なですね学びというところにライフのぐらいにはあのその支えとしており
ますたとえこれ
集計の1級の問題ですこれ
大学生とかがですね習うようなあの問題だと思いますけども
自由なところになってくるとなんと小学校5年生が再名所でこれ合格してしまったと
いうことでもうこういうような時代にどんどんどんどんになっていくんですよね
でもだんだんとですねその生涯学習という観点は日本がもう少し違う観点も入れていか
なければいけないという状況になってしまいました
というのはこれからのデータサイエンスとかそういった時代の中で
やはり数学というのがもっともっとそういった仕事とかそういったところに直結するよ
というような事をですね学んでそして使っていかなければいけないそんな時代になって
いますこれはアメリカのですね
職業ベスト3ですけども1が出たさんやです
とか
これあのそれぞれのと某もですねまぁ理系とかそういったところで直結する仕事って
いうのがあの実際に稼げるというような形になってきているわけです
ばそんな状況に対してですね経済界からももうなんとかしましょうよということで
経団連のですね会長がなんとか
あの文系と理系で別れたと言った大学教育をですね
見直すという機会を作んなきゃいけないですよという提言をはじめ
でだんだんと
日本政府もですねそんな動きに追随するかのようになってきて
そしてだんだん東高校生たちもですね特に男子の高校生は今 it のエンジニア
プログラマーになりたいというのが1になってきましたこれは
ものすごく前の10年20年と比べたらですね全然違う流れだと思います
でもここがちょっと問題です
国際比較の中で数学を勉強するとですね日常生活に役立つんじゃないかと思っている人
たち
これは天性の方が国債の方ですけども日本がしたの実践です
まだ低いレベルですね
4将来自分が望む職につけるためには数学ってそういったところが必要になるんじゃ
ないかというところも若干上がってきている傾向にありますがまだまだそこにかして
ないという状況です
まあそういった動きのなかで企業もじゃあ数学をですねちゃんと
学ぼうというような動きも出てきているそんな状況もこの中に出てきていまして
例えばビジネスで使える統計講座をやったり数滴のセンス向上トレーニングを入れると
いうようなところがですね
フジクラとかいい陶器とかそういうニコンさん
とかがですねそんな動きになってきているというところはぜひ知っておいてください
まあこの数学というのはですね実はどんな分野でも必要になってくる
現在と過去と未来ということですね比較するにも
そしてせいぜいするにもやっぱりそこの中で数学的なセンス
もしくは統計的な手法そういったところを使いながらですねこれからの未来を予測する
そういったところの中で数学は
大変使われてくるというようなところがあります
これはの世界の数学会がですねそれぞれの数学はどういったところで
ヴァイスディジーズのところに寄与するかというようなところで3番4番5番8番
911045というようなところですね
実際に明示しながらこれからのところです
数学はどういうふうに寄与するかということを考えていこうというふうにあのできます
のではそういったところもぜひご理解頂ければと思っております
で最後になりますがさあここで皆さんに最後の最後
聞いてみたいと思いますこれもね皆さん一言でちゃんと
ことができると思い
ますが14mar ら丸めるの日
はい14mar これさんが強くから3.1女で
はい円周率円周率先程言っても僕ずっと気を言ってました
さあ一緒にさてみましょうが9丸に入る言葉が何ですか
せーの
すみませあの肝心疑似でですね
漢字二字で世界は
通学でできているんですよねはい行きますよ
サーマルに入る言葉は何ですかせーの
はいありがとうございましたこれで失礼致します
[拍手]